Where is that?
Hey,
hey, hey.
question.
Hey
Hello everyone. Welcome, welcome. My
name is Janine Horton. My pronouns are
she and her. We're so glad to see you
all here. Everyone online, thank you for
coming and joining us. I want you to
know that you're not only welcome here,
but you are definitely celebrated here.
have a couple of announcements for you.
All right. If you are interested in
learning more about baptism and what
that means, then we'll have an
information class uh December the 7th
and the 14th. That'll be before the
services. And that'll be for baptisms to
occur on Sunday, January the 11th. So,
if you're interested, RSVP by scanning
the QR code.
All right. Christmas services. Everyone,
this is important news. Uh since our
rental situation doesn't make it uh
possible to have a Christmas Eve
service, uh then we're having our annual
Christmas service on Sunday, December
the 21st. It'll be at our usual time,
5:00 p. p.m. It will be a familyfriendly
service complete with carols, candle
lighting. Mark your calendars and invite
friends and family to come and be with
us during that time.
If you are anxious about being in a
church environment, if you're a part of
the um disability community or just
feeling fidgety today, then we have an
accessibility bucket to my left. In
there you'll find noise cancelling uh
headphones, fidget spots, coloring
sheets. We just ask that you return them
to the bucket when you're finished with
them at the end of the service.
All right.
I've lit the candles up front here as a
sign of the presence of Christ among us,
fully divine
and fully human.
Let's take a breath.
And now we're going to exit that kingdom
of noise and hurry and productivity.
And we're going to enter into the
kingdom of silence and stillness and
simplicity.
Enter a sacred space,
a place for prayer and worship and
adoration,
a place to behold Christ.
the revelation of God,
the heartbeat of creation.
Just allow the unforced rhythms of grace
to find you, to envelop you,
to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thank you, John.
If you guys want to stand with us, we're
going to open up with some worship
tonight.
I'm so glad that you guys [music] are
here and I just invite you into this
space to um connect with God in a form
that hopefully creates some meaning and
um shifts us out of our
practical [music] day-to-day
responsibilities and obligations and
instead creates this environment that we
get to enter into together that's
creative um hopefully soulful and
mindful and where you can be
introspective for a moment and reflect
on your own inner landscape and um allow
[music] God to be in that space with
you. Um
I'm reminded of that scripture in
Proverbs that [music] says, "Search my
heart, know my anxious thoughts, um see
[music] if there's any offensive way in
me and lead me in your way everlasting."
And I was reading that earlier [music]
um this afternoon and just praying that
God would be with us in this time and
that we would sense his [music] spirit
and his presence um being in this
introspective moment with us where we're
able to say, "Search us, [music] God.
Know us.
Be with us." So let's enter into that
together [music] tonight.
out [singing and music] of control. I
feel it losing my defenses. [music]
No, it's not easy [singing]
letting go and trusting you.
And if I'm [singing] being
honest, [music] I know that [singing]
you
know it's not easy [music] letting go
[singing] and
[music] you
will
brea rest here in your goodness. I know
[music and singing] you only it's my
confidence.
>> I will stop
brea rest here [music] in your goodness.
[singing] I know you only. It's my
confidence. [music and singing]
>> It's my
and out [singing] of control. [music] I
feel it losing my [singing] defensees.
No, it's not [music] easy letting go and
[singing] trusting you. [music]
[singing]
[music]
I know that [singing] though you've said
you've [music] got it, no it's not easy
[singing] letting
go and trusting you.
So we'll stop. I will stop
brea rest [music and singing] here in
your goodness. I know you won't leave.
[music] It's my confidence. [singing]
>> I will stop [music] brea rest here in
your goodness. I know you [singing]
only. It's my confidence.
>> It's my [music] confidence.
>> Here [singing] I am in the palm of your
head. [music]
Nothing can [singing] take me away.
Nothing [music] can take me away. Here
[singing] I am in the palm [music] of
your hand. Nothing can take me away.
[music and singing] Nothing can take me
away.
[music and singing]
Not a hide or a death or a lie inside my
head. Not a fear [music] or a fence.
Nothing can take me away. Let's sing
that again. Not a high or a death. Not a
lie [music and singing] inside my head.
Not a fear or a fence. Nothing [music]
can take me away.
Not a hide [singing]
or a death. Not a [music] lie inside my
head. Not a fear or a fence. Nothing can
take [music and singing] me away.
Not a hide or a death. Not a lie [music]
inside my head. Not a fear or [singing]
offense. Nothing can take me [music]
away.
Here [singing] I am in the palm of your
hand. Nothing can take me away.
Nothing can take [music] me away.
Here I [singing] am in the palm of your
hand. Nothing can take me away. Nothing
[music and singing]
can take me away. It's my confidence.
>> It's my confidence.
>> It's my confidence. [music and singing]
[music]
All right. I think we have a few kiddos
who can head out to kids ministry
tonight. Your teachers are going to meet
you over by the double doors.
All right. And as they make their
[music] way out, we're going to
transition into the prayers of the
people. So you can follow along on the
screens and read the sections in red
aloud together.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you. Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us. So, we [music]
lift these names and situations up to
you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace.
and a deep sense of your presence. Amen.
[singing and music]
flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, we [singing and music] want your
living
flowing from [singing] the heart of the
father.
Jesus, we want [music and singing] your
living
water flowing
from the heart of the father.
Jesus, [music] we want [singing] your
living
water
from [singing and music] the heart of
the father.
Jesus [singing] we [music] want your
living
water [music] flowing from [singing] the
heart of the father
Jesus. Sing that one last time. Living
[music and singing]
water flowing
from the heart [music and singing] of
the father.
Jesus, we want you.
Who are you?
I've cared [singing] a burden
for too long on my own.
I wasn't created
[music]
to bear it on.
I hear your invitation [music]
to let [music] it all go.
But I [singing] see it now. I'm laying
it down.
And [music] I know that [singing] I need
you. [music] I run to [singing] the
father. I fall into grace. I'm done
[music and singing] with the hiding. No
reason to wait. My heart needs a
searching. My soul [singing and music]
needs a friend. So I run to the father
again and again [singing and music] and
again and again.
Oh, [singing]
[singing]
[music] you saw my condition.
Had a plan from the [music] start.
You're for redemption
the price [music] for my heart.
>> I [music and singing] don't have a
>> for [music] that kind of love. I don't
[singing]
understand.
I can't [music] comprehend.
All I know is I need to you
run to the father. I fall
[music and singing] into grace. I'm done
with the hiding. I reason [music]
to [singing] wait. And my heart needs a
search. My soul needs
[music and singing] a friend. So I run
to the father again and again [singing]
and again and again. [music] Oh
[singing and music]
again and again. [music]
Oh,
[music]
my [singing and music] heart is been in
your sight
long before [singing] my
first breath.
running into [music]
your
arms is running to life
from [singing]
death. [music] I feel this rush
deep in my chest. [music and singing]
Your mercy is calling
out [music]
just [singing] as I am. You pull [music]
me in and I know I need you
now. I run to the father. I fall into
grace. I'm done with [music and singing]
the hearting. No reason to wait. [music]
My heart [singing] needs a sur. My soul
needs a friend. So [music and singing] I
run to the father again and again.
I run to the father. [music]
I fall into grace.
Done [music and singing] with the
hiding. The reason
my heart [music and singing] found a
searching. My soul found a friend. So I
run to the father again and again
[singing]
and again and again.
Oh
[singing]
[music]
again again.
Oh. [music]
[singing]
Oh.
[music and singing] Again and again
water flowing
from the heart of [singing and music]
the father.
Jesus, we want your [music]
livinging water, flowing
from the heart [music and singing] of
the father.
Jesus, we want [music and singing] your
living
water flowing
from [singing] the heart of the father.
Jesus, [singing] we want your living
[music]
water.
flowing
from the heart [singing and music] of
the father.
Jesus, we want you.
We want you.
[singing]
We need [music] your love.
We need your love.
God, we open our hearts tonight and make
room for you and your spirit and what
you want to do inside of us. What you
want to [music] speak to us as our
creator, our maker,
as Jesse to play. Can you guys just take
a moment to think about what it might be
that you're needing
from God?
If you can just name that with him
tonight.
Maybe it's strength.
or hope.
Maybe it's forgiveness.
Maybe it's restoration.
Peace.
Spirit of God, we make room for you to
come and do your good work in our
hearts.
Would we have soil that is ready to be
planted in,
ready to receive from you?
Would you find good ground where things
can grow and thrive?
your goodness, your peace, your
forgiveness,
your strength.
Ready our hearts for you,
God. We want more of you.
Help us to make room for it.
help us to hear your voice, to listen
for your voice.
It's in Jesus name we pray. Amen.
All right. Can you guys turn to the
person beside you and say, "The peace
[music] of Christ be with you." And then
you may be seated.
Well, grace and peace. It is good to be
with you all. My name is Brett and uh
pronouns he him and it's a joy joy to be
with you to welcome you into this space
and as always that includes those join
us online. Y'all are not forgotten.
Thanks for being with us and don't
forget to get your communion elements
for later in the service. We always love
when you can join in with us uh in that.
And uh yeah, and also just a warm
welcome to all of you. This your first
time or just your first time in a while.
We're really glad that you're that
you're here. So um let's see. The title
of my message this week is the process
of suffering. Woohoo. You're like,
"Yeah, getting all right." [laughter]
I am uh I'm I am I'm hopeful to bring
some life to it, though. You know, I
think suffering is sort of one of those
things we can spend our lives avoiding
or we can just kind of name it and learn
[laughter] how to to work through it,
you know, better. So, uh hopefully it
won't be, you know, kind of like a kind
of a message. But, um next week I want
to name we're um going into Advent and
so this kind of time of like heart and
mind preparation uh leading up to the
season of Christmas. So, um that'll be a
really special uh kind of few weeks as
we lead into the the Christmas service
that Johnny was talking about. And yeah,
so I encourage you if you can be here um
you won't want to miss that uh that
time. So let's see our our gospel
reading is uh from Luke chapter 23 verse
is 33 and 34 and uh it says this. When
they came to the place called the skull
they crucified him there along with the
criminals one on his right the other on
his left Jesus said father forgive them
for they do not know what they are
doing.
So the, you know, the the cross of
Jesus, it's an incredibly it's a it's a
powerful symbol. And I think if you
could say this even about a, you know, a
kind of image and a a picture of like
torture. I think it even has a certain
beauty um about it. And uh so my message
today, I'm not going to try to like sum
up, you know, all the theology of the
cross and all that it means. uh instead
I just want to give you kind of one
maybe approach, one angle um that kind
of sees the cross as this teaching and
really Jesus approach to the cross more
than just the moment of crucifixion but
even this kind of lead lead into it um
as this kind of uh process of uh of
suffering and a kind of approach to it a
teaching about it. Um now before we jump
in I want to give you like kind of a
quick footnote on this. So basically
theology uh about the cross and
sacrifice and suffering. Um I would say
it's a lot of nuance is needed on this.
Um
there's been some kind of like really
from starting like maybe the 80s 80s 90s
there was like uh feminist uh theology
and um what's called womanist theology
which is sort of like um a black
feminism kind of thinking about the
cross and seeing uh the ways we've kind
of preached it and taught it and kind of
the emphasis on you know sacrifice
sacrifice suffering uffing suffering. It
can be good. It can be good. That it it
kind of almost uh not almost but it led
to this a kind of uh too extreme view of
it where it was like it was just only
good and they started to kind of poke
holes in that in helpful ways. Um
pointing out for example that uh women
right and you can see where a feminist
is coming from that perspective. Women,
especially in the church, were often
taught to um be kind of in that uh
sacrificial
uh suffering role, often even at times
in like abusive marriages and the
perspective of like church leadership
and such was
was kind of seeing them almost through
the lens of Christ and then would say
like, "Oh, well, you know, this is
you're just um you're just suffering for
Christ. you're entering into Christ's
sufferings
and so can't you you know kind of this
it got really bad toxic you know where
it was kind of encouraging people
basically to end up staying in um not
good relationships abusive relationships
so right so feminists thought kind of
critiqued that and it was good it was
like a necessary critique um over time
that kind of that conversation's
continued and some feminists now are
kind of working to maybe recover some of
these notions
Because from their perspective, maybe
that pendulum got swung a little too
far, you know, to where it was like not
sacrifice good, sacrifice bad, you know,
just bad suffering, bad. No, just don't
don't even think about don't even try to
preach on that or talk about it or ah
because that's just leads us to abusive
paths, you know. And they said, well,
um, for example, they pointed out that
um, motherhood itself is sacrifice,
[laughter] you know, is there some
suffering in in even motherhood? and
they said, "Well, you know, what doesn't
feminism need room for for motherhood?"
You know, so that's kind of that's sort
of a whole conversation that's kind of
going on. And I name it because, you
know, just anytime I'm teaching here on
sacrifice, suffering, and such, I I
think we we need a lot of nuance. It
just can't be as simple as sacrifice
good, sacrifice bad, suffering, good,
suffering bad. This is like this is too
clunky. You know, what what kind of
sacrifice do you have in mind? what what
kind of suffering what's the context you
know uh to what degree is this kind of
willed and chosen to what degree is this
forced upon someone you know what I mean
so at any rate I just wanted to kind of
name that footnote right here at the
beginning u for those who might be
having some of those questions you know
rumbling around the back of their their
mind as we as we kind of get into this
so uh this idea of kind of the the life
of Christ and his journey to the cross
as this kind of teaching on suffering I
I came across this from a pastor um
named Peter Hos and uh his church of
conscious harmony, a contemplative
Christian community in Austin, Texas.
And what he kind of named, I'd always
seen the cross this way. What I hadn't
tuned into was the way the kind of days
really um months and years leading up to
the cross was this kind of journey into
suffering. That's what Peter Hos pointed
out that I was kind of like, huh, I'd
never I'd never thought of it like that.
I think I kind of had this separation a
little bit from like Jesus life and then
like the cross. And I didn't see this
kind of continual kind of journey into
suffering. And so that kind of got me
thinking. And so I want what I want to
unpack in this message is kind of the
maybe some phases of suffering that
might help you even kind of map a little
bit on kind of where you are in your own
you know journey and then give you some
handles for um how you can kind of live
in to that. Um so phase one of suffering
we'll call this imagining
imagining suffering. Matthew 16:21 this
takes place maybe 6 to 12 months uh
before the crucifixion. It says this,
"From that time on, Jesus began to
explain to his disciples that he must go
to Jerusalem and suffer many things at
the hands of the elders, the chief
priests, and the teachers of the law,
and that he must be killed on the third
day uh or and on the third day be raised
to life." And if you've read the
gospels, you know these moments where
Jesus kind of predicts this suffering
that will come. In fact, just a a few
verses after this passage I just read,
Peter takes him aside and like criti
criticizes him. is like you can't talk
like this. But Jesus like doubles down.
He insists like no no no this is how
it's going to be. And I think here you
have kind of imagined suffering, right?
Like this is at this point for Christ
it's all future
suffering. You know he's not it's not
something he's undergoing now. It's just
predicting like this is this is coming.
And uh I think we can kind of relate to
this in that we've all know the
difference between like imagined
suffering and actual suffering. And
these are two very different things.
Even though in the moment of the
imagined suffering, I think we often
think we know, you know what I mean?
Until we get into it and then we're
like, "Oh god, this is not what I
bargain for." You know what I mean? Like
this is no, no, no, no, no. I think um
maybe a little bit of a silly example um
considering our subject matter, but um
one example this in our lives might be
have you ever had this moment where you
told someone or a group of someone's
like about the like training plan,
workout program, couch to 5K you were
going to do.
You ever had this conversation with
someone like we're kind of in that time
now where it's November, you know, like
January is coming and sometimes people
make those resolutions or you know what
I mean? So, it's kind of like I'll just
tell you there's nothing easier than
sitting on the couch talking to someone
about the couch to 5K program that
you're going to do. You know, I mean,
the 5k I'm going to run the let me tell
you about the marathon. I'm going to
run, you know, it's oh, it's going to be
great. You know, um this is just a very
different uh experience
and it it often I think we actually get
into suffering, right? It just kind of
kicks us in the face, right? there's
just a world of difference between the
idea of suffering and actually uh really
truly
uh entering into that and suffering. Um
so this kind of leads to phase two uh
which is objecting,
right? This is when like we're actually
into
the experience and uh we've we've kind
of left theory now. We've entered
reality. We're starting to live it. And
as I mentioned, like it's way harder
than we think. And the mind goes wild. I
mean, at least I don't know about yours.
Mine goes wild. like every fiber of my
being is like resisting
um complaining, fighting, disliking.
And kind of weirdly, it can even come on
the heels of something we thought we
wanted, like you know, we get that
promotion or whatever, but now the
responsibility is like completely
stressing us out and the mind's just
going, you know, crazy. or uh a common
experience for folks here at the table,
you know, someone uh comes out
and it's kind of beautiful and
liberating. Um, and at the same time
there's like this backlash
where
friends start abandoning and grandma is
judging and the holidays are looming and
our mind just starts going wild with
like actual reality and the suffering
that we're undergoing,
right? or the the children that you
hoped and prayed for, they are wonderful
and meaningful, but also a total handful
and you're screaming at like a
2-year-old at 900 p.m., you know, like I
shared before, this is like always my
worst time as a parent's always like
bedtime. Um, and my kids were little. I
don't know how kids I thought kids would
get so sleepy after dinner, you know,
just kind of like, "Oh, I'm so tired.
Just ate, bellies full, you know." No,
it is like peak bath time is peak
energy. They're just like like going
nuts. And I would remember going into I
would tell myself like because of course
it was a routine every night like eight
years, you know, we're like bathing and
I couldn't get used to it. I was kind of
like, "All right, I would tell myself a
little pep talks like Brett, chill
Brett, it's tonight is going to be
contemplative Brett." Like just I'm
gonna this is I'm going to play this one
cool no matter what they do. And sure
enough, like some freaking towel would
end up in the bath, like in it. And I
was just like, "Oh my gosh, I'm
gathering." I would just at some point I
would just lose it. I'm just like,
[screaming and groaning]
you know, oh my, it was a disaster. Even
last night, I thought this would get
better. Now, of course, the kids, you
know, I don't have to bathe them. Thank
God. But now it's we're into the season
of um friends spending the night. So
like last night, I literally find myself
10 p.m. I'm exhausted,
so tired.
And it wasn't even that bad. They were
just being loud. You know what I mean?
And I'm literally like I won't say the
kid's name. I'm just like child. I'm
like, "Yeah, child's name, [screaming]
you know." Oh my gosh.
See, that's the moment like that's when
you can have all your plan. I love uh
what Mike Tyson had that saying about I
think he actually took it from another
boxer, but everyone has a plan until
they get punched in the face, you know?
And that's kind of suffering, you know.
Everyone has a plan. Everyone talks a
big game until they get punched in the
face by the reality of the suffering.
It's like, "Oh Lord, I no, I can't do
this. I can't do that." You know, this
is the objecting phase. I think I've
even um had kind of a similar
experience. It's maybe not quite that
dramatic, but a little bit as a a church
planter and and just being kind of in
church world like um you know, I'll say
there's nothing like sort of more pure
than like the idea of a church, you
know. And then there's like the actual
lived reality of a church. And um and by
the way, I'm not just putting that on
you all. You all are so disappointed. I
mean like me too. You know what I mean?
Like it's sort of all of us together
like yep, we are human beings. And uh in
fact, some of you will have if you
haven't already, like maybe you're still
in the honeymoon phase with the table,
like this is I found the perfect church.
I can't believe it. [laughter]
Well, uh you will have this moment when
it kind of reality sets in. It's like,
oh, they're just just people, you know,
and maybe even hurts, feelings, and
suffering, you know. It's like this is
like community. This is why often people
love the idea of community. They just
don't want the suffering that like
actual community and friendship and
relationship like really in real life
actually requires.
Uh and then the mind just goes wild, you
know, wild crazy objecting, arguing,
complaining, moaning, resisting.
And uh some of you some of you you're
there now, you know, the actual
suffering. You're like, "This marriage
is not what I bargained for. this
political climate. It is freaking eating
me alive. I I am one missed paycheck
away from financial disaster.
Maybe it's even just kind of identity
stuff, you know? Does anyone even see
me? Does anyone even notice me? Does
anyone love me or care even care that
I'm here? Like these thoughts just like
journey journey journey, right? You're
just in the midst of this this pain, you
know, phase two. It's hard. Actual
suffering is hard. What's interesting
and I think helpful though is that Jesus
had these moments too. You might recall
um that night before the crucifixion
uh in the garden of Gethsemane, Luke 22
beginning in verse 39 says Jesus went
out as usual to the Mount of Olives and
his disciples followed him. On reaching
the place, he said to them, "Pray that
you will not fall into temptation." He
withdrew about a stone's throw beyond
them, knelt down and prayed, "Father, if
you're willing,
take this cup from me."
It's interesting that that even Jesus
had this moment. It's like not so sure
about this cross.
makes me feel a little bit better about
all those times when I like talked a big
game, you know, [laughter]
and then when the actual suffering hit,
all I wanted was out. I just wanted out
no matter what. I just want out. You
know that moment when I don't feel up
for the journey.
Yeah, you've been there. You're not
alone.
You're not alone, friend. We've all been
there. This is the human condition, but
it's not the end of the story. Phase
three, accepting.
Accepting I do think um
well, you can see where back to my
little footnote at the beginning, you
can see where this becomes a little
tricky, you know, which is why I say
this needs nuance, but there is
something about accepting the reality of
suffering. Again, not talking about
staying in an abusive relationship or
something, but just in like life
presents us with these things. And hey,
if you can change it, if you can change
your circumstances in a way, great, go
for it. You know what I mean? Like, but
sometimes you're just in that mode.
That's when suffering is really hard
where it's like, no, there's not an easy
out here. And this is the moment where
actually
instead of resisting it, right, which is
the objecting phase, moaning,
complaining, disliking, like no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. instead
getting out of that mode and saying yes.
Yes. Like this this kind of willed um
acceptance. It's incredibly powerful.
And I I think um maybe a metaphor here
might be it's a little bit like being in
the objecting phase. It's kind of like
going through life trying to drive with
your foot on both the gas and the
brakes.
Can you imagine? It's like [laughter]
not a good way to drive, you know? But
it's there's this both move forward.
Yes. And a break. A no. No. Yes. No. No.
Yes. Yes. No. You know what I mean? It's
And you can see where when we finally
let our foot off the brake, then I think
what we're afraid of is like, well, then
my suffering will triple. If I say yes
to this, I I just accept that this
actually is how my life is currently,
and there's a certain sense in which I
need to accept it. Well, it's going to
get worse. Uh this is kind of the
paradox. What what do we what do we find
um that actually the resisting
itself, the breaking itself was so much
of the suffering itself, right? In
essence, kind of back to um last week if
you were here, we talked about the egoic
false self, right? And that's this
raring its ugly head again where it's
it's this this ego mind with its
ruminating and storytelling and
complaining and disliking and no no it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be when it is you know um that
is so much of um the problem itself
after um our last worship night about
was that a month month or so ago um
Maggie and I were having a discussion
about worship and and uh just kind of
what's going on there and we're talking
about like the various postures of
worship you know the kind kind of open
hands or open arms. Um, and this kind of
how it's this it's this picture of um
like not forcing something, but it's
kind of a picture of like receiving, you
know, when I think of the posture of
worship, it's not, you know, it's not
this, [laughter] you know, but instead
it's this kind of it's this openness.
And uh Maggie had just been thinking on
it for like a day or two and she said,
"I
is
is worship itself is it like is it just
a picture of like the spiritual life as
a whole?
And is it really all just surrender?"
And I said, "I I think so." Like I think
like 99% of it is
surrender is like God slowly but surely
bringing us to this place where we're
like
okay. Yes.
Yes. something a little practice I've
been working on is actually um receiving
my day in my life just as it is without
needing to like jazz it up, change it
up, distract myself to you know
something like and it's been so much
harder than I thought it would be. But
in a way it's like it's not some big
dramatic suffering. It's like a small
suffering like just to, you know, go on
a walk and not listen to a podcast, you
know what I mean? Which sounds
ridiculous, but it's like weirdly hard,
you know what I mean? Or to get in the
car and not distraction, distraction,
quickly, quickly, turn on the radio, you
know what I mean? But just to kind of be
or or um
yeah to to go and um just be present to
someone, you know, it's there's a
there's a kind of willed acceptance of
our life which is um surprisingly
difficult. But as we can say yes to it,
it's like there's uh I don't know
there's life begins to teach us, God
begins to teach us through like our
actual life. But again, it's sort of
like we have to take our foot off the
brake though to to start to get the
lesson to to learn. Um I see this it's
almost a kind of softening that can
happen, you know, becoming gentle
um to life, to ourselves, to others. Um
I heard uh well, one one way you can see
this is in like like older folks, you
know, they tend to um
kind of go into one of two extremes.
It's almost like if you live your whole
life in that kind of phase two objecting
mode, then that plays out,
you know, and you end up kind of
becoming this kind of embittered,
complaining,
incredibly intensely negative person.
You know what I mean? Because it's
almost like you can hide it in your 20s
or something, but let that play out for
80 years and you become a person. You
know what I mean? And vice versa,
someone who's able to kind of relax. You
met older folks who are just like very
relaxed. You know, there is a certain
surrender. There's an acceptance of even
themselves in their own failings and
shortcomings that allows them then to be
gentle with others. Uh I think this is
just a profound a profound thing to
start to understand and begin to
embrace. We see this phase in that same
passage from Luke uh 22 verse42
where so Jesus was there in the garden
right he says father if you're willing
take this cup from me and yet what and
yet not my will but yours be done
you hear the acceptance in that fact
those were some of the final words like
some of the last words of Christ on this
earth right not my will but yours be
done there's a kind of softening there
an openness ness and acceptance that
leads to phase four and I'll close with
this coming back to our opening passage
or I should say this phase four is
forgiving forgiving uh Luke 23:33 again
when they came to the place called the
skull they crucified him there along
with the criminals one on his right the
other on his left Jesus said father
forgive them for they do not know what
they are doing
what I want to point out is the
connection there between the the three
previous phases in that one. I think for
many of us, forgiveness is a bit of a
mystery, you know, like how on earth am
I supposed to forgive that person, you
know, like we often have a story or an
experience like not just the little
petty stuff. It's like, yes, I can
forgive that, you know, but like the big
things we're like, there's no way how am
I supposed to get to a place of
forgiveness? And I think in this sense,
uh, forgiveness, it's not something
that's really forced.
It it really is a a place a state we
find ourselves in
after
we ourselves have suffered some and
after we've gone through some of these
previous phases. Does that make sense?
So, um it's not as easy as like a to-do,
you know what I mean? Like do the
laundry and then forgive, you know, like
it's it's not going to be like that.
It's this it's this it's this journey
and it's something really we um I think
in so many ways we receive. Um
I also love this this line about Jesus
saying they don't know what they are
doing.
That's in that's incredibly insightful
because isn't our story they know
exactly what they're doing. You know
what I mean? They know exactly what. But
yeah, as you journey though and start to
see your own messed upness, you realize
like those moments when you are being
like your worst, so to speak, you are
often being bullied and pushed around by
your own past and conditioning and
suffering.
Does that make sense? So then you can
start to have mercy on others when you
realize like, oh, they're like the same
as me. You know what I mean? Like it's
almost like all of my shortcomings are
like kind of mistakes and an accident,
you know, or a kind of irrational like
my mind was just taking over, you know,
just being stupid, you know, but
everyone else's is like very cold and
calculated, you know what I mean?
[laughter] Um, when I think the truth is
we're we're all being um kind of pushed
around by these things. Um, I really do
think it's true. Humans don't know what
we're doing. Um, however, if by God's
grace and our own commitment to this
path, if we're able to kind of move
through these phases, I think we'll
enter this fourth phase where we truly
can learn to forgive everyone
for everything.
I think that's like kind of the pinnacle
of the spiritual life in a lot of ways.
Like when we get to that place where we
really are just naturally forgiving
everyone for everything.
That's that's a place of profound
freedom.
And it's a a place that I pray each of
us even no matter where we are on the
journey, you know, that each of us could
be pointed towards living into.
Yeah. A freedom. I pray finds each and
every one of you. In the name of the
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it. He said, "Take it
and eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." Then he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take this drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me.
So as you come forward, you can bring
yourself and your story and your
suffering and pain, whatever you you're
carrying in this place. Bring it bring
it here. Lay it at the the feet of
Christ, the one who suffers with and
alongside you. So the way we'll go about
this is we'll just go rowby row,
starting here at the front, forming one
line in the middle. Um we practice
what's called an open table. And if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate, then you're free to do that
regardless of your, you know,
denomination or theological beliefs or
whatever. If you want to connect with
Jesus, then you you come forward to
receive. The red is wine, the white is
grape juice. And finally, you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks like to take right away, some
like to come and kneel. Um, but no one
will lead you through the exact moment
of taking. So this is the table not of
the church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more. So come
you who have much faith and you who have
little, you who've been here often and
you who have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow and you who feel
like you failed, come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
If you guys want to stand with For this
last song, we're going to close um with
a song called The Breastplate of St.
Patrick. And I love that this song names
just a lot of little very relatable
moments of suffering that so many of us
have experienced, if not all of us. Um
but then just invites Christ into that
moment with us. So, we'll close out with
that tonight.
And my work takes me places I [singing]
don't want to go.
Christ be [music]
my heart aches with sorrow as I hit the
road.
Christ be [music]
with me.
When the care of my [singing] family
takes all that [music] I have,
Christ within
me. When I'm [music and singing] worn
and exhausted,
ashamed that I'm mad.
Christ defend
me.
I rise up today in [music] a strength
that is not [singing]
my own.
>> I'm held [music] by the promise of God
that [singing] I'm never alone.
When I'm [music and singing] tossed to
the side and I want to give up,
Christ [music]
be
[singing]
[music] when I'm breaking my back, but
it's never
Christ.
[music]
>> When I [singing] work hard, but [music]
else gets the reward.
God's eyes see
when [music] I ask for promotion
and they shut the door.
God's [singing]
ears [music]
hear me.
>> I rise [singing] up today in [music] the
strength that is not my own.
I'm held [singing] by the promise of God
[music] that I'm never alone.
When I climb [singing] the first [music]
steps toward a longheld
dream,
Christ
I leap out [singing] in faith and I
[music] hope to find
Christ be
[music]
>> Christ
be
Sorry about that. So in the moment that
was beautiful. Okay. Thank you all for
being here tonight. Uh if you are a
visitor, we would really like for you to
fill out a card or go online at the QR
code and fill out a visitor's card so we
can just check with you. Um if you want
to have a a more relational support or
spiritual connection, I think we can all
use that in our lives. The way we do
that here at the table is we do it
through our Meetup groups. So again, the
QR code is the key to all things table.
All right. Uh generosity [music] is a
key aspect of a life of adoration and
worship. And if the table is your church
home, then we invite you to scan that
magical QR code and uh to give
financially or you can go online at
thetabletx.org.
All right, it's time now for me to send
you out with a benediction.
If you would like to just uh raise your
hands in a posture of receiving or open
your heart uh to these words,
you are a child of God.
Yes, you are a child of God.
And this [music] is true on your very
best day and it's true on your worst
day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with
all of its yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between,
go and know that you are assured that
you are loved, that you are worthy,
and that you are accepted just as you
are.
go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
that you come in contact with.
Be blessed and we will see you next
Sunday. Amen.
I'll rise up today in the strength
[music and singing] that is not my own.
>> I'm held by the promise of God that
[music] I'm [singing] never alone.
When I climb [singing] the [music] first
steps toward a long held dream,
Christ
[singing and music] leap out in faith
and I hope to find
Christ [music]
be
Christ.